you're such a known person in this world
and you're you have an iconic career I
thought gee maybe this is a nice relief
for you to be able to kind of maybe
disappear as an author into this work
and then I flipped and I saw the picture
that you had used as the author photo
for the for the jacket for the photo and
I thought yes you were definitely trying
to disappear into this book I think do
we have it here yeah there it is that's
[Applause]
this is you first of all is that a
selfie in a car I don't know where you
are you underwater you know having
worked in movies for a lot a lot of
years you you all will often see the
poster of the movie where it's something
it's not a image from the characters
it's a it's opposed you know studio shot
with the actors like you know you know
just heads looking at the camera with an
attitude of some kind and I always load
and and general Julia maybe I've never
took part in one of those they told if
it wasn't them an image from the movie
maybe they could just do the other
actors but this I felt I think I've
always felt a certain kind of peace of
mind at my most bedraggled typically
because I would have a very great effort
either you know with an intention of
doing some good or an intention of
getting extremely intoxicated do I like
it both noble pursuits yeah you got to
commit to what you do yeah and
and once you've done that and you're
coming unto the other side of it that
kind of bedraggled feeling and it was so
freeing to be in a situation where I
could be constantly bedraggled in the
sense that I didn't have to show up in
somebody else's clothes at 600 o'clock
in the morning on a movie set I made my
own time in the writing of the book and
so I felt that I should represent it as
it was and so that's on an airplane it's
possible that there'd been some
environment prior to it let's see that
photo again I'm not sure yes okay yeah
you